bienvenido france24 encuentren la
organización mundial de la salud
advierte que el 80% de las dosis han
sido administradas en países ricos a
pesar de que sus habitantes no
representan ni la mitad de la población
global aplica esa tercera dosis podría
considerarse como una actitud egoísta
buenas noches gracias por la invitación
bueno acá en chile se ha generado
cierta discusión sobre todo entre entre
los expertos quizás en parte por ese es
el llamado de la organización mundial de
la salud a establecer una distribución
más equitativa de la de las vacunas que
existen a nivel mundial pero también por
la digamos
el tiempo en que se quiere aplicar ahora
sin sí por la pertinencia de esta de
esta medida es justamente ahora en
general la mayoría pensamos que una
tercera dosis sobre todo para quienes
han sido vacunados con síntomas puede
ser necesaria una dosis de refuerzo pero
no necesariamente el consenso de que
tenga que aplicarse ahora y claro uno de
los elementos que se menciona tiene que
ver con eso según una sobre inmunidad de
un grupo de un país y una falta de
vacuna en otro aparece como algo un poco
un poco extraño pero que sí pero también
hay estudios que señalan que algunas
vacunas dividen con el tiempo su
efectividad frente a la variante delta
que significa o significaría esta
tercera dosis que empezaremos a recibir
refuerzos anuales de la vacunación en
términos generales
claro o sea nosotros pasamos en chile
hace unos meses atrás uno de los picks
importantes con mucha mucha gente
infectada y mientras en paralelo se
hacía este proceso de vacunación que ha
avanzado bastante bien y hoy día hay una
situación bastante mejor con una
cantidad de casos mucho más reducida y
el digamos la expectativa es que eso se
mantenga pero no se puede descartar la
aparición de variantes como la variante
delta no es cierto que han mostrado un
grado digamos de capacidad de escape a
la inmunidad que generan algunas vacunas
y esto genera preocupación entonces en
ese contexto creo yo el gobierno de
chile decidió entonces utilizar dosis de
vacuna en re estimular las defensas de
algunas personas el problema está en que
todavía hay un 20% más que equivale a un
millón y tanto de personas que debiesen
estar vacuna y que no están vacunadas
bien se creo yo que una amenaza aún
mayor para que una variante como la
variante delta por ejemplo genere o
cause otro nuevo peak en los próximos
meses de un problema que no lo podríamos
resolver y por ultimo preguntarle si
conocen posibles efectos secundarios de
la tercera dosis y ésta es necesaria
además para los jóvenes y para personas
que ya se hayan contagiado con el hobbit
bueno en general
las vacunas han tenido muy poco efecto
adverso aunque algunos han sido
descritos sobre todo con la vacuna de
virus
como se llama esto los vectores virales
como lo como la de astrazéneca u otra y
justamente esa es la que se ha aplicado
por lo tanto se va a aplicar a personas
mayores porque allí se ha visto que
tienen efectos más leves y no es
esperable realmente que se genere un
efecto adverso porque reforzamiento de
vacunas se han hecho antes y ya ha
probado en millones de personas que la
vacuna en general son muy seguras por lo
tanto yo creo que ese es un tema que uno
quisiera casi descartar